la deuxième vague est inévitable
beaucoup de la deuxième vague je pense
que alors on s'est beaucoup trompé et
j'aimerais dire que vous savez désormais
on a 4 mois d'expérience sur un virus
globalement serre que même les plus
grands experts mais les plus grands
scientifiques non quatre mois de recul
sur un nouveau virus saison pour la vie
renaît nous regardent aujourd'hui même
le professeur aura ouais on peut c'est
un nouveau virus
on avance tous les jours honnêtement il
ya une pression psychologique va pas se
plaindre pour les médecins mais vous
rendez pas compte de la pression de tous
les jours et c'est de se mettre à jour
avec les nouveaux symptômes une nouvelle
chose qu'on découvre que peut-être on
aurait pu savoir il ya quelques mois
avec l'exemple chinois mais en bon on va
pas refaire l'histoire
donc voilà un peu de prudence je pense
qu'une nouvelle vague est inévitable en
tout cas on pourrait essayer de
l'amortir de la limiter et surtout de la
circonscrire certains pays sont très
bien sortis
l'accord et le vietnam singapour en
faisant des masques en les portant tous
les jours et même dans la rue puisque
une étude récente montre que même le
fait de parler permet de projeter des
postillons et le masque absorbe les
postillons de tester les gens de les
isoler donc une nouvelle phase de
l'épidémie va commencer peut-être celle
qu'on aurait dû faire dès le départ n'en
avait pas de masque pas de test matches
elle n'a pas grand chose très bien alors
juste il ya un truc qui est sorti d'un
président et a marqué vous dit le
président malgache donc le président de
madagascar affirme avoir trouvé le
remède contre le coronavirus une tisane
à base d'artémisine et d'autres plantes
qu'en pensez vous alors l'artemisia
c'est une plante qu'on peut utiliser
notamment dans le paludisme en fait lors
des bonnes pistes sont en cours le
traitement le plaquer ni de
l'hydrochlorothiazide un des traitements
qu'on donne justement dans la prévention
du paludisme est ce qui va ce maudit de
se positionner sur le même raisonnement
tout le monde je fais ce que j'ai
remarqué tout le monde un remède miracle
contre le cornet du russe 1 on avait la
chloroquine certains parlent des
antibiotiques
on a des antiviraux des corticoïdes pour
l'instant aucune étude sérieuse ne met
en évidence l'efficacité d'un traitement
on parle aussi du plasma la transfusion
c'est à dire que des gens qui les ya des
études qui sont en cours d'ailleurs en
trois régions de l'île de france
2/france pardon des gens qui sont guéris
qui sont curieux ils coronavirus qui
sont immunisés si on fait une
transfusion de leurs placements pourrait
guérir des personnes mais aussi des
études sur le don de sang de cordon le
cordon ombilical
vous avez des cellules souches
qui sont anti inflammatoire qui permet
de le calmer l'inflammation bref il ya
énormément de pistes on n'a jamais eu
autant d'études en même temps dans le
monde
mais attention aux découvertes
extraordinaires miraculeuse ou
d'apprenti sorcier la médecine c'est pas
de la cuisine c'est pas un peu de poids
un peu de sel même si on peut espérer
j'espère que quelqu'un trouvera un
remède on n'en est pas sûr encore